Uh, we were in the middle
of a training exercise
this morning, and, uh...
Sonny here ate about
2 1/2 pounds
of C4 plastic explosive.
If this dog moves too suddenly
he's gonna go up like Nagasaki.
So hopefully pretty soon
the C4 will mix
with the manwiches
I've been feeding
with him all morning
and nature will
run its course
and I will be able
to retrieve--
You can do it.
Jesus [bleep].
- Hi, my favorite.
- Hi. Yeah.
Hi, my favorite.
I'm gonna get this belly.
I'm gonna get this belly, belly.
I'm gonna get your belly,
belly, belly.
Yeah, you got his belly,
belly, belly, alright.
He gets the [bleep] point.
You got his belly, belly, belly.
Now back the [bleep] off.
- Hey! Hey!
- No. No.
- He's my friend.
- No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
No, no, no--
That's a little too friendly.
I'll see you later.
Please don't hump
the nice officer.
Here, come on.
Hey, hey. Hey.
Hey. How about right here?
Hey, how about right here?
Yeah.
Mission accomplished.
Ew!
You know, that's 90%
of law enforcement
is just perseverance--
Stick to the task.
- Hi, Travis.
- Right, sonny?
Hey, how you doing?